en guise de retour par rapport à leurs actions.
Donc, si on a un animal en cage,
il s'agirait de bonbons et de chocs électriques.
Mais c'est différent avec un smartphone,
ce serait une punition et une récompense symboliques.
Pavlov, l'un des premiers comportementalistes,
a démontré le fameux principe.
On pourrait entraîner un chien à saliver
juste avec la clochette, juste avec le symbole.
Ainsi, sur les réseaux sociaux,
la punition et la récompense sociales servent de punition et de récompense.
Et on en a tous fait l'expérience.
On a ce petit frisson --
« Quelqu'un a aimé mes posts et ça se répète. »
Ou la punition : « Oh mon Dieu, ils ne m'aiment pas,
quelqu'un d'autre est plus populaire. »
Il y a donc ces deux sentiments très communs,
et ils sont distribués de telle sorte qu'on se fait prendre dans cette boucle.
Comme l'ont reconnu publiquement bon nombre de fondateurs du système,
tout le monde savait ce qui se passait.
Mais voici le problème :
dans la recherche académique sur les méthodes du comportementalisme,
il y a eu des comparaisons de stimuli positifs et négatifs.
Dans ce contexte commercial,
il y a un nouveau type de différence
qui a échappé au monde universitaire depuis un certain temps :
si les stimuli positifs sont plus efficaces
que les stimuli négatifs dans des circonstances différentes,
les stimuli négatifs sont moins chers.
Ce sont les stimuli du marché.
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est qu'il est beaucoup plus facile
de perdre la confiance que de l'établir.
Il faut beaucoup de temps pour construire l'amour.
Il en faut peu de temps pour le ruiner.
Les clients de ces empires de modification du comportement
sont pris dans une boucle rapide.
Ils sont presque comme des traders à haute fréquence.
Ils reçoivent des retours sur leurs dépenses
ou leurs activités s'ils ne dépensent pas,
ils voient ce qui fonctionne, puis ils en font plus.
Ils reçoivent donc un retour rapide,
ce qui signifie qu'ils réagissent davantage aux émotions négatives,
car ce sont celles qui se manifestent plus vite, n'est-ce pas ?
Par conséquent, même les acteurs bien intentionnés
qui pensent qu'ils ne font que de la publicité pour du dentifrice
finissent par faire avancer la cause des gens négatifs,
des émotions négatives, des excentriques,
des paranoïaques,
des cyniques, des nihilistes.
Le système amplifie ceux-là.
Et il est plus difficile de payer l'une de ces entreprises
pour améliorer soudainement le monde et la démocratie
qu'il ne l'est pour ruiner ces choses.
C'est donc face à ce dilemme qu'on s'est retrouvés.
L'alternative est de revenir en arrière, avec beaucoup de difficulté,
et de repenser cette décision.
La repenser signifierait deux choses.
D'abord, beaucoup de gens, ceux qui en ont les moyens,
paieraient pour ces choses-là.
On paierait pour la recherche, pour les réseaux sociaux.
Comment paierait-on ? Peut-être avec des frais d'abonnement
ou des micro-paiements au fur et à mesure qu'on les utilise.
Il y a beaucoup d'options.
Si cela répugne certains d'entre vous, et que vous pensez :
« Oh mon Dieu, je ne paierais jamais pour ça.
Comment pourrait-on faire payer quelqu'un ? »,
je voudrais vous rappeler une chose qui vient d'arriver.
À peu près à la même époque
où Google et Facebook formulaient leur idée de gratuité,
une grande partie de la cyber-communauté croyait aussi qu'à l'avenir,
les émissions télé et les films se feraient de la même manière,
un peu comme Wikipédia.
Mais ensuite, des entreprises comme Netflix, Amazon, HBO, ont dit :
« En fait, abonnez-vous. On va vous donner une super télé. »
Et ça a marché !
On est maintenant dans cette période appelée « Peak TV », n'est-ce pas ?
Donc, parfois, quand on paie pour une chose, elle s'améliore.
On peut imaginer une hypothétique --
(Applaudissements)
On peut imaginer un monde hypothétique de réseaux sociaux à leur apogée.
À quoi cela ressemblerait-il ?
Lorsqu'on s'y connecterait,
on aurait des conseils médicaux utiles et fiables, et non farfelus.
Lorsqu'on voudrait obtenir des informations factuelles,
il n'y aurait pas un tas de théories du complot bizarres et paranoïaques.
On peut imaginer cette merveilleuse possibilité alternative.
Oh.
J'en rêve. Je crois que c'est possible.
Je suis sûr que c'est possible.
Et je suis certain que les entreprises, les Google et les Facebook,
s'en sortiraient mieux dans ce monde.
Je ne crois pas qu'il faille punir la Silicon Valley.
On a juste besoin de repenser la décision.
Parmi les grandes entreprises de technologie,
seules deux dépendent de la modification du comportement et de l'espionnage
comme stratégie commerciale.
C'est Google et Facebook.
(Rires)
Et je vous aime, les gars.
C'est vrai. Les gens sont fantastiques.
Je tiens à souligner, si vous me le permettez,
que si on se penche sur Google,
on verra qu'ils peuvent multiplier les centres de coût à l'infini
avec toutes ces sociétés, mais pas les centres de profit.
Ils ne peuvent pas se diversifier parce qu'ils sont accros.
Ils sont dépendants de ce modèle, tout comme leurs propres utilisateurs.
Ils sont pris au même piège,
et on ne peut pas diriger une grande entreprise ainsi.
En définitive, c'est donc tout à l'avantage des actionnaires
et d'autres parties prenantes de ces sociétés.
C'est une solution gagnant-gagnant.
Il faudra juste un peu de temps pour tout résoudre.
Beaucoup de détails à régler,
totalement faisable.
(Rires)
Je ne crois pas que notre espèce puisse survivre si on n'y remédie pas.
On ne peut pas vivre dans une société où deux personnes souhaitant communiquer
n'y parviennent que si cette communication est financée par un tiers
qui souhaite les manipuler.
(Applaudissements)
En attendant, si les entreprises ne changent pas,
supprimez vos comptes, d'accord ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
C'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)